foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
NBA bets we love the gang is all back
here how we feeling man how we feeling
on this Wednesday Ryan Celtics heat
little nerves no no nerves no nerves so
we're gonna smoke we're gonna smoke uh
you know all these little clips of Jimmy
Butler last year or he's like oh it will
be in the same position next year and
we'll get it done my ass you'll get it
done it's not happening this is Jason
Tatum's here so I feel great Greg thank
you for asking I hope you're off to a
fantastic Wednesday dude thank you you
feel great oh yeah it's Winter's only
Wednesday you know we are off to a
fantastic uh Wednesday MB how you
feeling any I know you got a best bet
for us but uh how you feeling about your
first baskets about your NBA bets uh
since we last talked I feel pretty good
man it's been a hell of a playoffs man
we've had some really good individual
performances we've been watching I don't
know what to say more about Nicole jokic
bro he is an absolutely
no he does it all but we're feeling good
over here we're trying to keep stacking
some money up so uh let's get to it baby
should he has should he have been the
MVP that is the question yes it's the
question of the day yes he should have I
think we should I I think as a
collective we should write a petition on
this show the three of us and send it to
the NBA to take the MVP away from Joel
embee I
earned that mvp but uh on that note
on that note I'm gonna welcome him to
the show right can I welcome I know it's
just like we can't talk about change we
have to enact change okay let's take it
away from embiid he doesn't deserve it
say it Greg he doesn't deserve it no
Joel embi beats actually deserves it
welcome to the show everybody my name is
Greg Ivory next to me your left is
producer Ryan
he thinks Joel embiid does not deserve
his MVP I think he does quote me on that
quote me on that yes to your right to
your right we have MB the man of the app
Michael Bolin uh make sure you guys drop
your Best Bets for tonight in the chat
we are talking about those he those
Miami Heat taking on Ryan's Boston
Celtics Ryan
what are the people talking about in the
comments uh darian85's here uh everyone
know who knows ball on this show knows I
love Darian I came in here and said Ryan
looks like you got a 10 over there uh
not true I think maybe the lights are
maybe just a little darker today uh I
have not been outside that much
unfortunately
um but uh somebody trucks in here I
think it was Chef Drew got uh said I got
a sneaky leg for you all with the
eyeball Emoji
um
where is Chef Drew at this current
moment with the sneaky leg I don't know
um so come in here drop us your locks
um El Bay given bowling some love MB has
been going crazy with those first basket
picks the stock up emoji
stop what's going up appreciate you I
see some Heavy Hitters in here today we
got Darian as you mentioned I see bat
bath Ave boy Jay Hernandez I Vibes are
high shout out Sam Evers by the way and
then we can get going shout out Sam
Evers in the chat Celtics minus wow that
looks like a million
minus one million that's a that's my guy
saying that's a lot of odds those odds
aren't going to work in our parlay today
though we need big odds yeah yeah it's
not gonna work uh oh yeah we need big
odds what are we doing what are we
thinking for this parlay
um
you know last week
we didn't do it
no this week's a new week are we gonna
jump on the strategy are we gonna change
the formula are we going to go we what
are we doing
we got to change the formula uh we had
some discussions
off camera instead of going for lower
odds why don't we just go for a long
shot man we've played the game we've
done minus at that we've done plus 100s
we've done plus 400s let's get to ten to
one drop some plays in the chat so we
could throw 15 bucks on it and win 150
bucks man let's have a night I I'm fully
with that can I say this uh Chef Drew
came back in gave us the lock gave us
some statistical analysis here here and
there it's bam one plus block
you mentioned that we were talking
before the show bowling uh I love the
amount of Bio tonight bam adebayo owns
the Boston Celtics
um so I think that's a pretty good place
for us to start if we want to go to
OnePlus box at -135 uh
I'm kind of all over this I I love this
play you got no argument for me I think
Bam's gonna have a big series and I
think if they expect to even make this a
long series he's gonna have to be really
great every night you know what he
brings on a defensive end and one block
should be easy we might catch this in
the first five minutes of the game
legit he should give us that it's only
-135 uh I'll take it I'm in the comments
I
I want your take on this one Ryan I want
your take on this one
Jason uh Tatum I'm assuming over
rebalances tonight
I'm just I'm not saying we have to take
this I'm just literally in the comments
in the chat talking to the people trying
to Vibe out
I don't hate it because I think the I
think bam is going to take up a lot of
the boards or take up a lot of the
assignment on Al Horford and Rob
Williams whoever decides to be in the
game at that point and I think somebody
on the Celtics is gonna have to step up
Tatum has been cashing I think it's at
what is it nine and a half uh
let's see
10 and a half now oh geez uh okay uh
this is a number then this is a
that's a big number well I do see Sammy
Sammy Dixon says Tatum over 10 so we can
go under the hook just to let you guys
know
he's had 14 12 11 5 and 10 in the last
five against the Heat specifically so
what you're saying Ryan is true he does
get freed up a little more in this
series against this matchup but he's
been hitting the glass like crazy all
playoffs so yeah I wouldn't be afraid of
ten
um you know we're gonna need some some
some plays that are close to even money
or plus money to get to ten to one but
235 is a good start with two legs and I
do expect Jason Tatum to have a big game
tonight on the glass yeah I'm with that
that's a good call out Greg I'll I'll
take the over 10 and a half here I'm I'm
with it uh there it is I'll go ahead
Ryan skrilla 847 uh Max truce three plus
three pointers as our as our good friend
yeah our good friend Sam Richmond would
say he likes the streus to get loose
um I but I've never heard that that's
pretty good yeah yeah that's it it is a
good one I'll give him I'll give him his
due but uh I
Max truce is hit or miss and his line
right now is at two and a half
I
think I like it I do
I think I do
how do you guys Max Bruce is someone
that is you know like the modern day
microwave if he gets cooking he might
give you 30. the only thing that I'm
hesitant on is I'm pretty sure he shoots
better at home they'll be on the road
yeah not sure it it doesn't make me
worried that he's not gonna hit it
because shoot or shoot but I will tell
you just to go back to the numbers
the last five against the Celtics he's a
three one five zero and two so a little
all over the place it's a game one he's
really good in game ones
I don't hate it I think Greg you should
just be the voice to reason here what do
you think
I'm deep diving in his numbers right now
I'm taking a deep dive on stat Muse
right here trying to look at his last
five games
uh he's shooting 34 from three I'm
trying to look at three point attempts
what is three where's three point
attempts
uh I can't find it right now I'm
depression
I got it
yeah I got it I got it he's putting up
about about
eight he's averaging eight in his last
game I mean his last five games
all we need is three
we need three he's averaging he's
averaging eight one eight attempts I'm
sorry okay all right all right yeah yeah
yes we just need three made and he's
averaging three made I like it
can I hand up here uh bagel and locks
was drop something that I was going to
say anyway uh Gabe Vincent
uh he wants to keep into action in
general I actually have a really tough
feeling as a Celtics fan that Gabe
Vincent might kill me during this series
I think over one and a half actually
might be
I just like the number better obviously
the odds are a little bit chalkier but I
like the number better than two and a
half especially like I get he's shooting
eight of them but if we need him to make
three that's almost fifty percent and if
he shoots better on the on at home than
on the road then I think yeah
where's Martin
uh Jason
oh boy this isn't good guys
what is is Martin on that list uh Ryan
yeah I
yeah one and a half that's a lock
over one and a half and it's juicy my
boy b-a let me look up his numbers y'all
can debate y'all can go in the comments
I don't hate it man we got to get to ten
to one somehow we're gonna have to go
out on a limb at some point yeah I mean
Caleb Martin has played really well
since uh since hero got you know injured
they're gonna need the other guys to
step up you can I can't imagine a series
where the heat hang around and struce
Robinson Vincent Martin don't have big
games they gotta have big games every
night or else this is gonna be a
gentleman Suite
oh
I'll take it
okay so we're at plus 660. we don't have
to have 10 boards by Tatum anymore we
can move that a little bit
I feel like let's try and get to the
place we're going to and then we'll and
then so you're the kind of guy that
wants to get to the destination and then
put your bags down then go to the
grocery store you don't pick up the beer
before you get there I uh no I actually
do pick up the beer before I get there
so that's yeah that's a change of
strategy for me but I feel like we need
to
yeah you're right I'm not I'm not I'm
not trying to blow up the process I'll
Trust it
um
all right well our Bagel unlocks is I'm
assuming that he's still talking about
gay Vincent so there's
10 10 plus okay so there's nine and a
half here
guys I'm willing to go crazy I think
Gabe Vince is gonna score 10. and then I
was going to say let's take Rob Williams
under rebounds because I think that is
going to to smackaroo
smackaroo oh my God we trust you with
those Celtics Ryan but like
why do you think it's going to smackery
get like talk us through it bam out of
Bio is far too physical for Robert
Williams it's just not I think if
somebody's gonna be taking on that
assignment and winning the assignment
it's going to be Al Horford I I don't
see Robert Williams having this type of
game I usually I don't think he usually
has these types of games against the
Miami Heat anyway it's usually Al
Horford who kind of takes the uh takes
the roll here so
um
uh and listen look I think if we take
that right now we're at five legs and
we're at 2400. so we've got autobio one
plus blocks Tatum over nine and a half
rebounds Caleb Martin over one and a
half threes gave Vincent over nine and a
half points and Robert Williams under
seven and a half rebounds
we can afford to lose one I think it
depends on which one but I think we can
afford to lose one
so my my the one that I would afford to
lose in my opinion is the Rob Williams
one because it's an under and that's
just a personal thing you are the
authority on the Celtics so I'm not
saying you're wrong I know but if this
guy gets five boards in the first half
we're all gonna throw our phones into
the river dude and I don't want to do
that I want to get to the fourth quarter
with a chance or have already cashed
this thing
I agree I agree
I was gonna say I think the one that I'm
least confident is for some reason is
Jason Tate
we can move it down
I mean he's gonna get at least six to
eight boards we can move it down like we
said we're trying to get to ten to one
well Ryan if if
Robert Williams isn't grabbing the
boards doesn't that mean Jason Tatum
after your album no yeah I mean it
definitely does but like we don't need
it at nine and a half uh my my fear
could we do all boards all under yeah we
could do all under nine oh for for Rob
for Rob oh I'm down with that that'll
hit
oh yeah
that'll that'll that'll help out
uh under nine and a half what does that
have us at
um right there still that was it not is
it not still the oh they moved Jason
Tatum back up okay so then let's see
what we could do with Tatum here because
I yeah again we we have we have we have
the ability to play around uh
all right that's where we're at let's
try eight
that's pretty good
I like that that's I see bagel and locks
I've seen bagel and locks given bath Ave
boy a little uh props here Lowry over
four and a half assists at plus 100 he's
got six five and eight during the season
against them and has been dishing them
all through the playoffs it's just
another play to consider if we're not
super confident about either of the the
Martin or Vincent legs
hey shout out to bait bathe a bath a
bath
he doesn't like it when you when you
mispronounce the name he doesn't like it
it's hard to it's hard to pronounce the
name
boy uh boy shout out to you that was a
that was a scoop that was definitely a
scoop the Kyle Lowry scoop
uh it's up to us to bite on it or not I
I do we like that better than the the
the Caleb Martin play
only reason why I would say I like it
better than Caleb Martin is because
you're going for variants uh I think uh
yeah uh bagel and locks was in the chat
saying the volume is there he shoots for
a game you need him to go 50 I'm not
against it
I think it's I think it's pretty lucky
uh and you never know in a game one so
that's just my take
we still need a little bit more juice
yeah that messed up the odds like we
need like a little bit though it's not
anything crazy
well maybe taking that Robert Williams
to like eight and a half
yeah so if we go if we add Kyle Lowry
over four and a half assists and then we
go yeah I think we go Rob Williams under
eight and a half bowling are you
comfortable with that would be like yeah
yeah all right
I I I I I like the the Rob Williams
let's move let's move Big Rob first yeah
see what it does
gets us there that's it
that gets us there
there it is this is a fun this is a fun
little parlay boys
yeah nah this one's definitely fun this
one's definitely fun are we locking this
one in that's the question are you guys
we need thumbs up in the in the comments
in the chat
uh are we locking this one in
how how are you feeling about it Ryan
you haven't said much
I I haven't said much because I think
we're feeling good it feels weird to not
have Jimmy uh in this at all which is
what the chat is kind of alluding to at
this current moment but I think I I like
where we're at I also don't
you never know what kind of game you're
gonna get from Jimmy I am fading Jimmy's
assist tonight but I also I don't want
to add in two unders into this parlay
um I think we're I think we're on the
right track here
I am I I do too can you scroll up it
looks like it dropped a little bit
which means yeah we're still there so
we're still over a thousand so yeah we
might as well go ahead and put our stamp
on it and this is more fun to me
honestly I'd rather put 20 bucks on a
plus a thousand than put 20 bucks on a
plus 400. so
we're done with singles bro we gotta hit
homers yes we're getting let's go we're
getting lfg's we're getting
um thumbs up emojis so I I I think it's
safe to say we're gonna lock this one in
Ryan can you uh review
the parlay one more time you can never
say it with a straight face can you
now one time uh bam autobio one plus
blocks
Gabe Vincent over nine and a half points
Jason Tatum eight plus rebounds Kyle
Lowry over four and a half assists and
Robert Williams under eight and a half
rebounds all that five legs
plus 10 13. and if you're new to FanDuel
Place five dollars on this on this baby
and get a hundred and fifty dollars in
bonus bets
guaranteed
whoa
[Music]
Ryan I have it
the graphic just came up tell them that
one more time
if I must Greg five if you bet five
dollars on this you got a hundred fifty
dollars at bonus but it's guaranteed
from FanDuel if you're a new customer go
do it opt-in have some fun and win I I
mean you could fade this if you'd like I
don't think it I I am strangely
confident in in this parlay
um then again we have been confident for
months and we haven't hit one you don't
have to mention that man the bikes are
good enough dude yeah this is
and I like the first take I like I like
the first take Ryan not the second take
but it's okay uh yeah it's okay we move
we I'm a one take guy I'm a one day once
you start asking me to do more I can't
you should okay
we move we move what a tailor parlay
make sure to head on over to FanDuel
check it out
um and win some money with us but now
it's time to talk Best Bets look at
everybody placing that BET right now
it's close we're in right now it's time
to talk Best Bets
and uh ah let's I'll start it off guys
I'll bet lead off here
I'll bet lead often will go Ryan then
we'll go Bowen all right so uh
my best bet I was on FanDuel earlier
taking a taking a gander looking at uh
series odds and I don't know if you guys
saw but I am all in on the Lakers
and the series odds is up to plus 2 30.
now if you guys were watching that game
yesterday the Lakers made tremendous
adjustments from the first half to the
second half they took Anthony Davis off
of jokic as on ball defense they took us
they took him off of jokic with the
on-ball defense and had him coming over
as like a Rover helping out on jokic and
that changed jokes uh I feel like it it
altered his game a little bit it had him
thinking about what he was going to do
next Lakers did not obviously pull out
the win yesterday but Ryan
they made some adjustments that caught
my eyes they made some adjustments that
caught my eye and they're sitting at
Plus 230. plus 230 LeBron James Anthony
Davis you know I say put y'all money in
on them man put the money in on them go
get that plus 230 and uh you might not
see this number again might not see this
number again
that's true for sure Ryan I'm I'm
excited it looks like you're ready to
explode it's just like this thing it's
the guy is talking about how it altered
yokich's game he knows I bet under nine
and a half assists for jokic at what
point did his game get altered yes he
had a triple double in the first quarter
essentially bro
he did he did that's why I said in the
in the second half fourth quarter oh he
didn't have to play in the second half
pretty much
the floor will be yours here soon and it
looks like you're all fired up so this
is perfect I just I can't I can't he I
can't hear the name jokic right now
um okay so uh from the same director who
brought you uh the Sixers and Celtics
exact series order bet
um I come to you with a Celtics heat
exact uh series order bet now hear me
out hear me out the Celtics
on the road are 11 and 5 in their last
16 Road games
that's unbelievable 3-0 in closeout
games
now
look at this little one right here this
little guy who's sitting here at plus
6500 I don't know how Celtics to win
game one it's a lock everyone's on heat
plus eight and a half tonight if you
want to bet the spread tonight bet
Celtics by the state and a half they're
gonna blow them out it's gonna be
embarrassing whatever game two Heat come
back they tie up the series I just don't
think that they go down 2-0 go to Miami
now Miami welcome to Miami as Will Smith
once said
um rip game three Celtics win game four
Celtics win they go up 3-1 now the
entire world is on the Celtics to win in
five right everyone everyone's like
Celtics are winning in five
the heat go back big game in Boston and
beat the Celtics now everyone's thinking
whoa whoa whoa hold on are the heat
gonna come back from 3-1 is this Jimmy
Butler is this is this the script no
it's not the script the Celtics go back
on the road and win game six win it 4-2
on the road to winning a championship
Banner 18 but it's plus plus 6 500. and
the haters last time were like oh my God
you only got it at plus 1100 dude it's
65 to what
let's go I put 1539 on this baby 15 39.
you can get what will the haters say why
would you put 1539 tell them why because
it gets me a thousand
there you go exactly a thousand dollars
back
he's chasing a stack I want a k there it
is there it is my man Ryan's going with
the exact uh MB
in in exactly on the series Ryan 65 to
one okay
I wish you the luck I will say this by
the way real quick and then bowling you
can do your Spiel people are gonna say
this that you would have better luck if
you rolled over the winnings on the
money line from every game no you
wouldn't don't say it because they're
gonna get in the comments of the post
they're gonna be like if you just rolled
it over hey hey genius the Celtics like
minus 390 on the money line tonight you
can't do it that way
tired of people talking like this tell
them tell them producer Ryan get it I
don't know let him know can't reply to
every comment man you know
all right go ahead uh wow sorry
all right well I'm back with my first
basket plays for this evening I hit last
night in the parking lot of Portillo's
shout out to Portillo's in Chicago great
food establishment if you know you know
um not getting cute tonight there's been
a lot of data between these two teams
over the last few years played in the
Eastern Conference Finals three times in
the last four
56 of the time bam wins the tip uh 91 of
the time Robert Williams wins the tip
we've got mystery
what will the starting lineup be
that's the variance that I don't like so
one of the hottest scores first
basketball year for the Celtics has been
Jalen brown one of the hottest first
basket scorers for the heat all season
long bam out of Bio I like the matchups
I think these teams know each other
really well there's no reason to do
anything crazy they're just going to get
active feel out game in game one I'm
playing the hits I'm not getting crazy
give me Jalen Brown give me bam out of
bio
if I get two in a row
watch out y'all
I'm ready let's get it dude you're
getting hot at the right time
yes sir that's the plan man
I've Dove way too far into the first
basket like dolls like I I can't tell
you my DMs look crazy people are like
you should do this collab with me on
this and yeah it's like I do this for
fun so also PSA if you're a unit shamer
you are an absolute loser that's all I
gotta say you are a loser and you
shouldn't be buddy
that's a good PSA I support that my drug
my drugs like does it aggressive PSA
there's nothing else to be said go ahead
wait can I can I give a PSA real quick
because Michael Ritter jumped in the
chat here and said uh exact order sees
game one sees game two sees game three
sees game four
guarantee if the Heat win a game in the
series you will see him on Twitter
saying nice win for my heat that's a
guarantee yeah
remember this moment remember that
moment and remember our parlay make sure
you guys remember our parlay remember
our Best Bets remember Michael bolin's
first basket remember Ryan's exacto
remember my Laker future
but in order for you to remember the
parlay we got to have Ryan read it one
more time
just read the parlay for the people
Brian it's in a graphic brother we have
it
over nine and a half points Jason Tatum
eight plus rebounds Kyle Lowry over four
and a half assists and Robert Williams
under eight and a half rebounds plus 10
58.
I got a bad number
screenshot screenshot screenshot
remember the parlay ride with this on
fan dual uh let's Get on Up out of here
guys it's time to go make some money
it's time to go make some money my name
is Greg Ivory for producer Ryan and the
man we like to call MB Michael Bolin we
are out of here
peace
all right
[Music]
[Applause]
oh
[Music]
come on
all right
[Music]
[Applause]